well good afternoon it's a tremendously
powerful report that Alex has done it
speaks to the daily reality that we in
the International Rescue Committee see
both in countries in the Middle East and
in Africa where failed States are unable
to contain conflict and now on the
shores of Europe where people are
exploiting the desperation I think that
was the word she used and it's
absolutely right the desperation of
people and the fact that there aren't
properly organized and ordered routes
for people either to be returned to
their homes if they are not suffering
from the threat of persecution or for
them to be resettled in cases where they
do have that well-founded fear of
persecution that is the definition of a
refugee all of the evidence that we have
from people who talk to us is the fact
that these wars in Somalia going on for
30 years in Afghanistan 25 years now the
Syrian conflict on top are overwhelming
the systems that exist and how do you
make that decision whether people should
be helped to resettle or in fact they
should be sent home the United Nations
has a very well-established definition
of what it is to be a refugee was APIs
tablished after the Second World War the
definition is that someone who has a
well-founded fear of persecution is a
refugee as opposed to an economic
migrants and in your introductory
comments about 20 million of them
globally are refugees there's one
refugee every five or six seconds at the
moment because of the number of civil
wars that are going around the world but
twice that number are internally
displaced people in countries in the
Middle East but also across Africa where
we work we see lots of people who are
displaced within their own homes and the
obvious response is that at a time when
humanitarian aid is under pressure we
need to be doing more if you like
upstream in countries in the Middle East
in Africa as well because if you don't
make the humanitarian efforts upstream
to provide shelter to provide health
care to provide education if you don't
do the work there then the sense of
desperation will grow as I saw for
myself in nazare which is a country in
the middle of Africa it's a trade route
I'm sorry to use that word for
or people who are being smuggled across
Africa and if there isn't proper
provision in countries like that to halt
the flow of people then they will end up
on the shores of Europe or or elsewhere
you're spoken of doing more work
upstream as you describe it you're the
CEO of International Rescue Committee
and what is your organization doing to
prevent this humanitarian crisis when we
have about 15,000 staff in 30 countries
around the world we're working to
provide health care to provide education
for kids to ensure there's proper water
and sanitation and it's a telltale sign
of how desperate things are that we've
had to deploy some of our staff to the
greek island of lesbos where a thousand
people are arriving a day and wearing
one of the transit centers there were
five toilets for 3,000 people but the
vast bulk of our work is in countries
like Lebanon Jordan Turkey Iraq in the
Middle East in Congo in nazare as I say
where I was recently and in Somalia
itself so we're working to try to make
sure the conditions that people are
forced to live in are in fact livable
and that there is a basic modicum of
dignity for them there it has to be said
that at a time when there are 60 million
people fleeing conflict at the moment it
too often feels like a losing battle and
that's why the calls which to be fair
have been led by british governments of
both parties for international aid to be
stepped up are well-founded but it does
sound quite reactive i mean you can't
prevent the wars you can't prevent the
conflict which really is the real cause
isn't it you're absolutely right to say
that but i would say two things partly
on the basis of my experiences of
foreign minister but also now is in my
experience as the chief executive of a
humanitarian organization we need far
more effort on the diplomatic front to
tend to those wars that do seem endless
I mean if you take the stereo example
that's the largest humanitarian conflict
in the world moment it's produced more
refugees 4 million refugees from that
conflict into neighboring countries but
the whole diplomatic effort is one UN
official trying to broker temporary
ceasefire in the moment
absence of a drive for a political
solution in Syria the sense of
desperation in other conflicts where UN
peacekeeping forces are underfunded and
undermanned that's what creates the
conditions where these conflicts spill
over not just into neighboring states
but onto the shores of Europe so the
first thing I would say is that it needs
to be a far greater level of diplomatic
attention political attention to the
conflicts themselves we can't just throw
up our hands and say that they're
insoluble the other thing to do of
course and to pick up your word
humanitarian organizations like ours
need to plan better we need to be sure
that we're not simply in the reactive
mode that you described and that's why
organizations like IRC we're doubling
our emergency capacity with pre
positioning people and goods to make
sure that we can respond within the 72
hours that we're pledged to do so and
and in your view does that international
attention which perhaps might be lacking
at the moment does that include military
intervention we're a humanitarian
organization and we look to political
settlements rather than military ones
the vital thing physical the political
settlement might be that perhaps
military intervention is what is needed
as a last resort as it might be well
obviously there's a in the cook in the
conflicts where we're providing
humanitarian help whether in the Middle
East or elsewhere there's a range of
military actors and interventions some
of them from governments some of them
from non-state jihadist players and we
have to deal with the consequences as a
humanitarian organization obviously the
key thing in the Syria crisis though is
that for four years there has been no
agreed political vision for the future
of Syria even the Geneva talks that were
brokered by Kofi Annan the former sector
general the UN broke up within days of
their conclusion with contending views
about what had been agreed and it's the
absence of that political settlement
that I think has empowered a whole range
of radical and other groups and led to
the fracturing of Syrian society in the
most appalling way in your view then has
the international community failed these
vulnerable people is there something
that they're not doing that they should
be as of today
there's definitely a collective failure
no one could look at the scenes that you
are reporting and see anything other
than first a failure to tackle the
problems at their root cause secondly a
failure to establish effective
humanitarian protection in the countries
that are in conflict or in the
neighboring states which is the best
place to catch people to meet their
needs and thirdly there's obviously been
a collective failure in Europe as well
when it comes to organizing proper
provision for people who are fleeing I
should point out to a European audience
that in the United States there was a
similar sort of case last summer with
tens of thousands of children fleeing
from three central american states
including Guatemala and El Salvador and
the kind of scenes that you're seeing in
Europe were seen on land at US border
crossings last year so this is a global
problem it needs a far more systemic
global response and it needs to buttress
the efforts of organizations like the
International Rescue Committee
organizations like ours which are on the
ground it needs to buttress those
efforts with far more effective
political intervention otherwise we're
forever running to stand still now
people at home will live watched Alex
Crawford's report and have seen that the
detention centers while actually holding
pens we're probably glorifying them
calling them detention centers and
wondered why it excuse me there isn't
anything that we can do to help these
people when we know the condition
they're in and where they are we've
found it very very difficult to get into
Libya for the kind of security reasons
that Alex Crawford referred to however I
can speak to the situation in Greece
where we've had to deploy some of our
teams and we precisely are attending in
what you rightly call their you call
them holding pens detention centres I
mean I think we know that they fall far
short of anything that could be
considered a basic level of organization
and living we're literally building
sanitation facilities water provision
because without that then there's even
more desperation and even more incentive
to be carried across the rest of Europe
so there are there is work going on my
organization others are due
important aspects of that but I think
the critical message that's got to go
out is that there needs to be upstream
help as well as intervention on the
shores of Europe we're actually on the
borders of Italy and Greece where you
see some of these appalling scenes and
there are recent reports some of the
attempts to save people in the waters of
off Europe becoming a bit less
successful there's been progress over
the last few months for those are there
been some reports that they're actually
faltering I think it's very important
that a message of very real clarity goes
out on the back of the report that
you've done that actually there are more
people are going to come out of
desperation unless their basic
conditions are addressed